it starts with a star player of this
team from axis really reimbursed as one
of the top five players in the world
Naxos an angle coming line still in
Trevino keep in mind North only has
three digits money this will be a first
round for the missile reach that nice
gone like that he want her to let them
here he wants a knife to pull his money
16 under per second clever he's always
taking you minute would like a name here
so that means snacks look at this
forward position that he has all the way
up by the Trinity catches or energy
dropped by such a good kill second one
coming in snacks just a very aggressive
holy remain and it works how beautiful
he's going to turn around for the
potential tricky and it will be taking
down Dozier they've got to kill snacks
just to get anywhere further on a
Matthew Fox out there no support of a
duel no strange potential so we gotta
get the ball has almost got one where
are the balls out of ammo SWI for sacks
to sort it off he can't see a single
thing but it's broke they need this
round they must have this from a passion
sound and out-and-out sexless 102
tempering always going to get the double
kills insects for the world to clutch
Russ still with the frag stacks out to
trade now with the AWP and no one to
support him and the smoked out on the
wall this is definitely so awkward walk
back through the smoke has going to be
right in there ten seconds now stack yes
one second one trying against our PK
this is now a two one three
oh no this could be one time for the
Gilberts max getting one is a one the
saw is working insects to office five
and buzzes pro win the round
look out
they go early snack hit the end of the
cap we've got a very slight gap it's
perfect for him to work with because
he's got convict he's also got the
information of across I don't think the
flag hit him in time but I think passing
those are there these turns fine resist
take the beads in the open and they
closing its time one be three looking
for the shot he's going to get it and so
now the one be to do they have time no
snacks again the 1v1 and now all he has
to do is go for the pink draw off and
the snacks will plusses so palm goes off
to make sure no one's going to push up
at msl wasting no time is gonna turn in
bathrooms that twice actually caught
deep because that's it back away but a
on the AWP get to hookers now as well
they still go line up for a form come on
Zack get the eight it's right in front
of you and you've got all five how many
X's are we going to see in big quote and
then some snacks